this might be a good place to kind of
compare influenza
the flu and covid in the context of the
discussion we just had which is um how
deadly is coved so you mentioned covet
is a very particular kind of steepness
uh
where the x axis is age
so
in that context could you maybe compare
influenza and covid because a lot of
people
um
outside the folks who suggest that the
the lizards who run the world have
completely fabricated invented covid
outside of those folks kind of the
natural
process by which you dismiss the threat
of cova to say well it's just like the
flu the flu is a very serious thing
actually um so
in that comparison
where does kovitz stand
yeah the flu is a very serious thing it
kills you know 50 60 000 people a year
something i found that order depending
on the the particular strain that goes
around that's in the united states the
primary difference to me are the there's
lots of differences but one of the most
salient differences is the age gradient
and mortality risk for the flu
so the flu is more deadly for two
children than covet is
there's no controversy about that
children thank god
have much less
severe reactions to covet infection to
then that due to flu infections and rate
of fatalities fatality all of that i
think you mentioned um
i mean it's interesting to maybe also
comment on i think in another
conversation mentioned there's a u-shape
to the
to the flu curve
so meaning like there's actually quite a
large number of kids that die from flu
yeah i mean the 1918 flu the h1n1 flu
that the spanish flew in the u.s killed
millions of
of uh of younger people
and um that is not the case with covid
more than um
i'm going to get the number wrong but
something like
70 80 percent of the deaths are people
over the age of 60.
well we've talked about the fear the
whole time really
but my interaction with folks
now i want to have a family i want to
have kids but i don't have that real
firsthand experience but my interaction
with folks is at the core of fear
that folks had
is for their children
like
that
somehow
you know i don't want to get infected
because of the kids like
because god forbid something happens to
the kids and i think
that obviously that makes a lot of sense
this kind of
the kids come first no matter what
that's number one priority but in for
this particular virus
that reasoning was um
not grounded in data it seems like or
that emotion and feeling yeah it was not
ground it wasn't at the same time this
is way more deadly than the flu just
overall and especially to older people
yes
right so the numbers when when the story
is
all said and done
the covet would take
many more lives yeah
so i mean point two is sounds like a
small number but it's not a small number
worldwide what do you think that number
will be
by the you know that's not that's not
like but would we cross i think it's in
the united states it's um
the way the desert currently reports
like 800 000 something like that do you
think we'll cross a million seems likely
yeah do you think it's something that
might continue with different variants
what well i i think um so we can talk
about the end state of kobe the end
state of kova is it here forever
i think that there is good evidence of
immunity after infection
such that you're protected both against
reinfection and also against severe
disease upon reinfection
so the second time you get it it's not
true for everyone but for many people
the second time you get it will be
milder much milder than the first time
you get it with the long tail like uh
that lasts for a long time yeah so just
there's studies that uh that follow of
course people who are infected for a
year
and the reinfection rate is something
like somewhere between point three and
one percent yeah um and like a pretty
fantastic study out of italy's found
that there's there was one in sweden i
think there's a few studies that found
there's some similar things um and the
reinfections
tend to produce much milder disease much
less likely end up in the hospital much
less likely to die um so what the end
state of covit is it's circulating the
population forever and you get it
multiple times
yeah
and and then there's
i think studies and discussions like the
the best protection would be to get it
and then also to get vaccinated and then
a lot of people push back against that
for the obvious reasons from both sides
because somehow this the discourse has
become less scientific and more
political well i think you wanna like
the first time you meet it is going to
be the most deadly for you
and so the first time you meet it is
wise to be vaccinated the vaccine
reduces severe disease
you